après 24 heures d'une veillée funèbre
qui a tiré plus de 200 000 personnes au
stade de soccer de la ville de Santos le
cercueil du roi Pelé a été fermé à 10h
ce matin et ici sur un camion de pompier
prêt pour son dernier voyage
[Musique]
le cortège parti du stade pour un
parcours de 7 km a été accompagné tout
au long d'une haie d'honneur de
supporters du grand joueur brésilien
mort d'un cancer à l'âge de 82 ans
sur le chemin la dépouille de pellet est
passée devant la maison de sa mère
céleste
âgée de 100 ans
parmi le concert des Loges qui a reçu ce
joueur exceptionnel celui du nouveau
président brésilien
conduit à sa dernière demeure un immense
cimetière vertical à 600 mètres du stade
où il a reconnu la gloire en comptant
plus de 1000 buts un record inégalé
[Musique]
ici normand Grondin Radio-Canada
Montréal
[Musique]